hello
i just wanted to make a quick video to
introduce you to what is probably or
what is definitely the biggest change
that we've ever made in the history of
the khan academy we've introduced a new
learning flow that tries to engage
people more we've heard from a lot of
users that there's a lot of content on
khan academy they didn't know where to
start they didn't know what level was
appropriate for them and so we've we've
spent a lot of time thinking about this
and what you're about to see is our new
learning flow so i'm a new user and it
gives us a nice little welcome message
and i say cool let's explore
so
when you log in you'll see this mission
the world of math and right now as we
launch that is the only mission that we
have and it will essentially walk
through all of the math exercises that
we have on khan academy over the next
few months you're going to see other
missions missions aligned to grade
levels missions aligned to preparing for
a test missions aligned to being able to
do some type of a project you'll also
start to see missions in other subjects
now these squares that you see this is
for those of you who are familiar with
our knowledge map you can kind of view
it as a condensed knowledge map for the
particular mission that you're thinking
about
so here there are 482 boxes each of
these represents a skill it represents a
type of math problem
so what we're going to start right now
and i highly recommend you do this as
well it's actually kind of fun is we're
going to start with a pre-test this is
to address the issue of where do i start
on khan academy what are what are the
exercises that are most appropriate for
me so i'm going to actually take this
pre-test right now so let's start the
pre-test
so if i see anything that is completely
daunting to me i should just say i
haven't learned this yet
what is the area of the rectangle well
that's just going to be 3 times 9 which
is 27 square inches
let's just say for the sake of argument
let's pretend that we're we haven't
learned algebra or geometry that's why i
haven't learned this yet
i haven't learned this yet and this is
an adaptive test here if i answer
questions right it's going to get harder
or go to more advanced topics if i get
questions wrong it's going to give us
simpler or more basic topics
move the orange dot to four thirds so
four-thirds that's one-third two-thirds
three-thirds and four-thirds
submit my answer
and i have to do five more problems so
this isn't too long of a thing here so
similar triangles well i said i'm going
to pretend like i haven't taken geometry
yet so i'm going to say i haven't
learned this now they gave us a
proportion 9 over 2 is equal to what
over 18 well we multiply the denominator
by nines we have to multiply the
numerator by nine so it's gonna be nine
times nine is eighty-one
and
there we go i've i've done my pre-test
and now the system is actually building
a model for what i likely know and what
i likely don't know
and we'll look at that in a second
so now you see that some of these tiles
changed colors gray means that i haven't
even practiced this thing yet while blue
means that i've shown that that the
system thinks that i i might know that
at a reasonable level and the deeper the
the the the darkness of the blue the
better that i actually know that so
let's actually start looking at these
so you can see here you can see here
that i can go on each of the concepts
and says i'm practiced for continue for
four
congruent segments it says right here
need practice or it hasn't started for
points lines and planes and if you click
on any one of these you can go directly
to that exercise so based on how i did
the pre-test it immediately figured out
what i probably know well what i might
not know
that well
and now this is key instead of having
the old khan academy where you just had
this huge knowledge map and you said oh
i guess i'll work on something one of
these 500 things that i see in front of
me this now will recommend what the next
best thing is for me so let me see so
reading tables two
so i can start working on that the table
below shows solar panel installations by
state during the last fiscal year except
one entry is missing so this entry is
missing and if i'm completely confused
by this i've never seen it we have a
video right here that should hopefully
help explain that concept
let me go over here and it says for this
one i have to get five in a row and if i
get five in a row i'm going to get to
that practiced state so
i will i will
just continue touring but i don't have
to do exactly this one this is what the
system recommends the most is the next
best thing but then there's other things
that it thinks should i should also be
working on right now so say finding
absolute values
what is the absolute value of negative
6.5 well that's 6.5 likewise we still
have videos there
and i got one out of my five correct
and if you have a coach or if you are
someone's coach the coach can also make
their own recommendations obviously we
have a lot of coach tools so that a
coach
can keep track of what a student is
working on and then based on that the
coach can recommend particular exercises
to be focused on or to be prioritized
now once you've spent some time on the
system your learning dashboard might
look a little bit more like this and to
get closer and closer to master to get
deeper and deeper shades of blue there
not only do you need to practice it get
five in a row and that sometimes might
change depending on the exercise but
later on you need to show that you still
know how to do that thing in a mix of
many many many different types of
problems and the place that happens is
right over here which we call our
mastery challenge this is the this is
the the tool that you want to use
repeatedly in order to get those those
squares as dark as possible so let me
take a mastery challenge negative seven
minus three i
the absolute value of five well that's
just five
this triangle is this triangle
equilateral isosceles or scalene so it
is definitely isosceles if it was
equilateral these would be 60 degrees so
it is isosceles you have two common base
angles so you see it's going through all
of the different types of the
mathematics to make sure that not only
have i remembered how to do these not
only have i retained the understanding
of these concepts but i also can do it
in a mixed environment where i have to
also recognize hey what is the tool i
need i need to use right now
what are the factors of 18 so let's see
we could have one we could have two
three
see four is indivisible five isn't
divisible six is
nine is
and eighteen
and i could have used this little tool
to help me with that but if you know the
factors you can just type them in so
let's check our answer
plot 10 comma 6 and select the quadrant
in which the point lies
10
comma 6 and sitting in the first
quadrant
move the orange dot to negative 3 minus
2i
negative 3 minus 2i
and now i'm completing my mastery
challenge and i'm going to get
essentially a report for what what did i
achieve by completing this mastery
challenge
and it's showing us the things that have
gotten darker based on the fact that
these are things that i had practiced in
the past but in the in this last eight
problems i showed that i still remember
them and i could do it in a situation
where i'm getting a whole mix of
problems and so it's our hope that you
enjoy this as much as i just did that
this learning flow really makes sure
that you know where to start that you're
starting on things that are at your
level and not only are you learning new
things but you have an opportunity to
review those new things and you have an
opportunity to make sure that you know
when to use those things when you when
you're faced with a whole mix of
problems so i look forward to seeing how
you can fill out your knowledge map here
fill out all of these skills and and
fulfill your mission in the world of
math and the future other missions and
we really want to hear from you to
figure out how we can make this entire
experience better so i encourage you to
go down to the bottom of these pages and
say
give feedback and tell us what you think
tell us what's working for you what's
not working for you and if you have
ideas for for things that might make it
even better let us know